hello my name is beau Carnes and I run
the Freak Ocampa org YouTube channel
we're currently the biggest ActiveX
software channel on YouTube our channel
focuses on posting long in-depth courses
and we post these courses from a variety
of contributors in this tutorial I'm
gonna share insights into YouTube's
algorithm I'll share tips for creating
your own software YouTube channel and
we're gonna hear advice from a variety
of successful YouTube creators even if
you're new to software you can benefit a
lot from starting a YouTube channel in
fact most of the tips and advice I share
in this video will be applicable to any
type of YouTube channel not just
software channels I think starting a
YouTube channel can benefit developers
at any stage of their career you don't
have to be an expert you don't even have
to know anything about a topic to teach
someone about the topic all you have to
have is an interest and a desire to
learn actually that's just what I did
when I started my first JavaScript
training channel so I created my own
YouTube channel this is before free code
camp and I had JavaScript tutorials I
didn't really even know that much about
JavaScript before I started the channel
I would learn about the topic so he
could make a video about the topic and
the process of making the videos turned
me into an expert and then when I went
to get a job I was able to point to my
videos to show that I knew what I was
doing and it helped me get a job before
you start a channel you need to decide
the goal of your channel your goal can
have an impact on a lot of things about
your channel so here are some common
goals which are not mutually exclusive
some people want to help others learn
you may want to build a body of work
that will lead to other career
opportunities you may want to give
yourself a reason to learn or maybe
promote a paid resource maybe you just
want to make money through YouTube ad
revenue sponsorships and affiliate links
also you may want to promote your brand
or company when thinking about the
videos you want to make on your channel
and you may think about how there's
already a lot of videos on that
same topic but don't worry about that
because there are tons of different
learners in the world so there's got to
be a learner out there that can learn
best from your teaching style also I
can't stress this enough you don't have
to already know about a topic to create
a video about a topic Krang a video is a
great opportunity to learn
you're gonna want to try to figure out
what type of software channel you want
to start I category software YouTube
channels into four types we have
tutorial informational live coding and
software entertainment I'm going to give
some examples of all of these
interspersed with tips from some of the
creators different types of channels
different types of videos appeal to
different demographics for instance a
software attainment channel is going to
appeal to a wider demographic than a
software tutorial channel so you need to
keep your goals in mind so you don't get
discouraged if you see other videos
getting way more views in your videos
just depending on what you're trying to
accomplish for your channel so a
tutorial channel primarily features
software tutorials this is the best type
of channel if you want your channel to
help you get a job or if you want to
sell Pig courses this style sometimes
less focus on your personality than
other channels so you can see here are
some top tutorial channels and some good
examples of what tutorial channels are
like so as far as tips I people ask me
this all the time and I really I don't
want to say I don't like the question
but I don't feel like I have a great
answer because there's no special
formula I didn't do promotion so I don't
I don't have much advice on promotion
what I did was just make videos I just
was I was consistent I think that's the
best advice I can give is to be
consistent and it's gonna be
discouraging at first you're gonna get
no views you know and you're gonna make
no money and you're spending your time
but the more consistent you are if you
if you're making good content and you're
uploading you know every week people are
gonna start to come so that's that's the
the best advice I can give and don't
stop because if you stop making content
your channel is just gonna go to [ __ ]
and even at my level at whatever 800,000
subscribers if I just if I don't make a
video for a month or two months my
analytics are just gonna it's just going
to be a straight down slope
and it's it's very stressful you know
doing YouTube especially full-time is
very stressful because if you if you
don't have any ideas that week you know
and you can't make a video your your
analytics go down and that's your
livelihood you know so it can be
stressful but you do you know you want
to be consistent
another thing is be yourself don't don't
try to copy people it's it's okay to
watch other people and get ideas from
them but don't like straight up copy
someone because it's already out there
you want to be unique you also don't
want to be fake I know that there are a
lot of fake people on YouTube and a lot
of them are successful like the family
vloggers and stuff that are all giddy
and happy and stuff and then they're
miserable off-camera you want to be
yourself you know for me I I like to
talk to you guys like I talk to my
friends you know I don't jump on camera
like hey guys we're gonna we're gonna
build an application today and and
Lottie died and that's just not my
personality you guys would think I was
friggin high or something you know is he
getting back on drugs if I if I acted
like that so I just think that being
yourself is is genuine and people pick
up on that and I think that ultimately
that's one of the things that that's
helped me out the most and then the last
one I have is to find your niche and
basically what I mean is keep your
content you know all in the same area
don't do a development video or a
tutorial one day and then the next day
do your favorite movies and then the
next day do a family vlog because people
tend to subscribe the channels for a
specific thing for me it's usually
tutorials I also do videos on you know
like videos like this self-help to help
you in your professional life help you
be more successful come up with ideas
stuff like that you know so you want to
just kind of stick to to a certain realm
don't go all over the place because
people won't know what to think of you
or why they're watching you unless you
just have a fantastic personality and it
doesn't matter what you do there are
some channels like that but I've seen a
lot of channels fail because they just
just all over the place so you know you
just want to find find what you're good
at and stick to it
an informational channel has
informational videos about software
development they usually focus on soft
skills and other information that
developers should know and just you know
sometimes you see multiple styles in one
channel you'll see tutorial videos and
informational videos on the same Channel
but here are some examples of some good
informational channels to kind of give
you an idea of what type of videos
you'll see on those channels
hey guys is your boy Joe back at it
again coding face.com your boys back and
I don't did it again one more time
listen people love with people hate it
it is what it is what do I do here on
YouTube very simple okay I just come
here be myself I talk to you guys just
like I'm talking to my friends okay I'm
just having fun with it okay that's the
number one thing that I do on YouTube
have fun okay second thing is I actually
help people get jobs by giving them
advice and and telling the little things
that help me okay and even things that
I've seen in the industry that I feel
like nobody told me so I should tell
others about it so like that they can be
more prepared for job interviews you
know what type of programming languages
that you focus on how to get into
certain jobs right how to make your life
easier as a junior developer and that's
what I do here and it's a informational
slash you know tutorial slash you know
lifestyle type of channel okay if you
like the type of content then definitely
check out coding phase right cuz that's
what we do here we try to help people
out and at the same time you know we
just let people know like what we do
again how we have seen growth you know
we went from parking lot attendant you
know working in a warehouse doing all
this other stuff all the jobs that you
could think of right I see people all
the time come up and back man I'm an
uber driver hey I'm doing deliveries I'm
doing this and that and my bro at the
end of the tunnel
there's a light trust me I saw it all
right I learned how to code I did
everything that I needed to do I put in
those hours so you can also get there
too okay now by the way for any
that wants to get into this whole system
this whole world this ecosystem of
YouTube
my advice is be yourself don't copy from
anybody okay have fun
alright that's number one I think that
should be the number one thing for
everybody cuz I'll be honest with you
YouTube is not easy right it's a lot of
hours a lot of work that you have to put
in right don't kill yourself over it but
you know have fun with it okay
don't take things too serious sometimes
we overthink things
you know when I first got into YouTube
I've been doing this for like four years
before I was even starting to get into
YouTube bang but because I was so
worried about what are the people gonna
think about me but do I sound smart
enough or is this a topic that I can be
talking about now I don't care now I
just come in and have fun okay and
that's my advice to you guys just come
in have fun
enjoy yourself don't copy for what other
people are doing right if you do that
you're gonna be successful it might take
you a little bit longer right but it's
not about getting the numbers of it's
not about getting a million subscribers
not about having you know a whole bunch
of money it's not about that it's about
having fun like one thing that I can
tell you guys on my community is we have
fun we do live streams and we have fun
we enjoy ourselves you have a long day
of coding and you want to come home you
want to relax that's what we do at
coding phase comma we give you advice
we'll help you out but at the same time
we make sure that the subscribers have
fun and if you want to get into YouTube
right that's what you should do
whoever it is if it's five people ten
people that's watching you have fun with
those ten people okay that's just how it
is
at the end of the day you will become
successful and just how anything else in
life is right you put in the time and at
the end of reward is there alright so
anyways guys shout out to everybody that
you know supported me here or free Co
camp and love you guys man stay tuned if
you want to check out my channel check
it out coding face another type is live
coding this type of channel mainly
focuses on people live coding viewers
can see the actual thought process that
goes into creating a program it can also
be helpful to see how LiveCode errs
solve problems in real time although
some people are so good at it it can
almost seemed as polished as a tutorial
channel like for instance the coding
train live coding is great for building
a community because you often get to
communicate with viewers directly during
a stream and this is also a style that
you commonly see live coding with other
types of styles on the same Channel
if you're interested in live coding I've
learned a few things than live coding
for a few years and here's some of the
advice that I think it'd be most helpful
on the technical side don't worry about
getting a fancy microphone or webcam you
can use the built-in webcam to get
started and the built-in mic that's how
I got started and I stuck with that for
a long time before I got anything else
and no one ever complained about the
audio or video quality when you actually
do start start live coding I recommend
just live coding whatever you're you're
normally doing whatever you're
comfortable with if you're doing a
tutorial you can live code that if if
you're working on open source projects
live code that it doesn't have to and it
doesn't have to be something you're
really good at they say if you just want
to do a side project with some new
technology you can you can do that when
you are actually doing the live coding
do your best to explain what you're
doing I recommend setting aside a
specific time for questions for checking
out the live chat and a time for coding
I split it up with a Pomodoro session so
25 minutes of coding and then five
minutes of of chat if you try to look at
the chat while you're coding you end up
not knowing either one very well and
there's just too many interruptions and
you can't you can't code very well like
that I recommend if you can try to show
your face because your facial
expressions will convey a lot of your
meaning especially for your viewers who
aren't native speakers to whatever
language your live coding and
I do recommend though that that's not an
option for most people so you know
that's I live coded for a long time
without showing my face and I was
totally fine and nobody said I want to
see you okay I just decided to do it
because of your being able to convey my
meaning more try to keep in mind that
people watching might be completely new
and have no clue what's going on so if
they ask a question that might seem like
maybe like almost like a joke that it's
so basic try it you know don't laugh at
it they might be new it might be a
legitimate question and if you laugh and
you're gonna just ruin that person's
experience of coding for that day and
you set the tone for your stream so if
you stay positive then the stream will
be generally positive if somebody goes
negative in the chat you don't even have
to address it you can just block them or
you could address it in a way that
doesn't escalate the situation if you
respond with negativity it'll cause more
negativity if you respond to a criticism
that's pretty harsh with you no thank
you
and try to figure out what the would you
can gain from that then that's much more
beneficial than you know responding with
something like defensive right so
hopefully you do some live streaming and
good luck the final type is software
entertainment this type of channel has
the potential for the most views
creators use programming to create
projects that are interesting to a very
wide demographic the videos focus more
on the outcome of the program and not on
the actual code used so this type of
channel like I said there's a it reaches
a very wide demographic you don't
actually have to be interested in coding
to really enjoy watching the videos on
these channels so once you design your
goals and the type of videos you want to
create
you're gonna have to do some setup and
planning here's some things you're going
to have to do so this is a screenshot
from my personal robot family youtube
channel first of all I want to point off
to the side there's a bunch of accounts
under one username one in my email
address bocardo gmail.com and we have a
bunch of different accounts these are
brand accounts so when you create your
YouTube channel it's good to create it
as a brand account this allows you to
keep some separation between your
personal Google account and your
software YouTube channel it's going to
still use the same login as your Google
account so you don't have to keep track
of another username and password and
then you can also add additional people
as managers of the account you're also
going to have to determine your channel
name so in this case it's robot family I
personally recommend using your name as
your channel name so like I would use
the name BOE Karns although you will see
you'll see an example already showed you
that a lot of people have had success
using other names but if you use your
name as a channel name it can help
better associate you with your content
so you're also going to have to develop
some things like your channel icon and
your channel art and then maybe a video
watermark to appear at the bottom of
each video that you're playing so those
things you can either design them
yourself or you could consider maybe
hiring someone off fiverr.com or
something like that but you're just
going to have to make sure you have all
those things you should also determine
what kind of intro you want not everyone
is going to have an intro but you may
want to intro that you have on all of
your videos I wanted a piece of advice
keep it under five seconds this should
be really short because if you if your
intro is too long people just get bored
and just kind of click off your video
before they even get into your video you
also may want to consider other
consistent things you want to add your
videos to set them apart like you may
have a sign-off line or a prop or maybe
you wrap in all of your videos something
like that to make your videos stand
apart
so once you've done the high-level
planning for your channel it's time to
start thinking about the specific videos
you want to make the first step is
brainstorming so just write down every
idea you can possibly think of after
that you just have to start narrowing
down that I'd those ideas to the best
ideas and eventually you'll come up with
a good list of videos that would be good
to create so once you figured out what
specific video you want to create you're
gonna have to do some researching
because remember you don't already have
to know about the topic beforehand but
if sometimes it can be good if you
already know about the topic beforehand
you won't have to do as much researching
but if you don't know about the topic
beforehand you're gonna have to do quite
a bit of researching so you can make the
video as good as possible for the
audience and you're most likely gonna
have to write a script for the video and
if you're making a coding tutorial
you're gonna have to write the code for
the video beforehand
recording and editing here are two of
the most important things when it comes
to recording first of all use a good
microphone and second of all if you're
gonna show code on screen make it as
large as possible if you have bad audio
or tiny code it's gonna cause people to
stop watching immediately before they
even see the real content of your video
it may be hard to believe but almost one
third of people watching coding
tutorials on the free code camp Channel
watch on a mobile phone you know people
are watching from all over the world and
so you want to make sure your content is
accessible as possible and so make sure
the code is as large as possible so for
audio almost any USB microphone will be
better than the built-in mic on your
computer if you can afford it consider
one of these microphones we have the
blue snowball the audio technica at2020
Ford a mic do some tests with recording
audio on a cell phone so depending on
what phone you have and what computer
you have there's a chance that audio
recorded on your cell phone could be
better than audio on your computer so
you'd have to record the audio
separately and then just add it in and
editing later if you're going to show
yourself on video like I'm doing now the
cheapest way is just to use a webcam or
your your cell phone's camera a lot of
cell phones actually have pretty good
cameras but if you want to take things
to the next level
consider one of these cameras but no
these cameras are probably not necessary
if your channel mainly consists of
coding tutorials but we have a few
canons this Panasonic and these are all
good options a good camera is especially
important if you are creating
informational or software entertainment
videos you also may want to include
screen recording in your video if
using a Mac I recommend using quick time
for both screen recording and video
recording and it should be pre-installed
on your computer already if you're using
windows there's a shortcut key to begin
recording your screen just any time you
you just press Windows key alt R if you
want to show video of your screen at the
same time as video of you talking you
can use OBS software OBS is a great open
source software that a lot of live
streamers use although I actually use
Final Cut Pro to make my face here
appear on top of this video when you're
recording your screen always make sure
the main content takes up as much room
on the screen as possible remember a lot
of people are actually watching coding
tutorials on mobile phones so all text
should be as big as possible you need a
very good reason to show a window that
is not full screen when recording a
tutorial it can be helpful to use two
screens you can record one of the
screens for the video and use the other
screen for your script and completed
code so here's something that some
people do to make their coding tutorials
even more polished first record the
whole tutorial with the screen capture
where you're talking over the screen
capture and then transcribe the audio
then go in and make some edits like
maybe make some things more clear add
some jokes or something and then
rerecord the audio and then put that
audio the rerecord audio over the
initial video and then it's gonna look a
lot more positive before you should
probably be editing your videos to make
them flow smoother and to edit out any
mistakes you can use editing to edit out
any arms or pauses or loud noises and it
could just make things seem just a lot
more professional this is especially
important if you're creating is some
software entertainment videos or even
informational videos but pretty much
everyone should be doing some editing
for very simple editing you can use
iMovie on Mac or moviemaker
on Windows but these programs are very
limited I personally use Final Cut Pro
but that is a little
pricy here's a few other free video
editors that offer more features than
iMovie or moviemaker
we have open shot video pad and
Lightworks after you decide what
software to use for editing watch a few
tutorials to learn about the basic
functionality of the software another
option is to hire someone to edit your
videos even if you already know how to
edit videos hiring an editor can save
you a lot of time if you can afford it
so you don't have to create thumbnails
and titles you can have the world's best
video but nobody will find out about it
if they don't click on the thumbnail to
grow your channel it is important to
create quality content but it's almost
equally important to use thumbnails and
titles that will cause people to click
on your video thumbnails are important
for all videos but in my experience
thumbnails are more important for
software entertainment channels and the
titles are actually more important for
software tutorial channels so here's
some tips for designing thumbnails some
of these come from the YouTube creator
Academy which has some pretty good tips
so first you should brand your
thumbnails by using consistent colors
fonts and graphics and stuff like that
also you should use the rule of thirds
this will help you compose interesting
and dynamic images so the rule of thirds
is where you've divided the image up
into thirds and you put all the key
things in the image on the line that
would be a third the way into the image
the next thing is to design for mobile
and desktop thumbnails are gonna show up
in different sizes across YouTube and
sometimes people embed your video so
check to make sure your thumbnail looks
good in multiple sizes that it could
show up on and then finally get ideas
from similar channels you can look for
channels that are similar to what you're
trying to do and see kind of what the
general idea and styles that they use
and that could give you some ideas
although you do want to make sure that
your thumbnails are distinct to your
channel so next image editing software
you need you're going to need software
to create your thumbnail so the top
image
software is Photoshop to use it you must
sign up for a monthly subscription
service and so there are some cheaper
alternatives so the most popular free
image editing software is [ __ ] I did use
[ __ ] for years and eventually I decided
I needed something more user-friendly so
I purchased affinity photo that's this
third icon here the features and the
user experience were much better than
[ __ ] so I was pretty happy to be able to
do that it also has a one-time cost
unlike Photoshop that has the
subscription model another good option
is its pixel meter which is kind of
similar to affinity photo
they're both one-time costs that give
you quite a bit of features choosing a
title it's best to pick a title that
people are searching for there are two
main ways to find out what people are
searching for we have YouTube search
autocomplete and Google Trends so let me
show you how to use Google search
autocomplete to figure out what you
should title your video let's say you're
creating a video about JavaScript
frameworks just go over to YouTube I
have the dark mode on so and go to the
search box and I'm just gonna type in
JavaScript frameworks now what you can
do is see what things are being
suggested so right after JavaScript
frameworks it says JavaScript frameworks
2019 JavaScript frameworks explained
JavaScript frameworks tutorial now these
are all words that people are commonly
searching for so now because of this
autocomplete we know what people are
searching for what words people are
adding with JavaScript frameworks when
they search for JavaScript frameworks so
in this case maybe I'll call my video
JavaScript frameworks explained
- 2019 okay one other tip I am signed in
right now but generally you want to do
this on incognito mode if you do it in
incognito mode then the search
recommendations won't
based on your search history at all
another way to figure out what people
are searching for is on Google Trends
let me show you how you would use this
say you make this for our Python course
and you're thinking about what what
should you title this should you title
it Python course is that what people are
searching for well let's find out so I'm
going to go to trends google.com that's
what I'm on now and I'm going to search
for Python course and now I can add
another search term I can compare to
other search terms so I'm going to
compare Python course to Python tutorial
and then where it says web search here
I'm going to switch it to youtube search
so now I'm seeing the relative
popularity of different search terms on
YouTube so we can see here that python
tutorial is way more popular than python
course so maybe I was thinking about
calling my video Python course but now
after I see this Google Trends I'm going
to use the word tutorial instead of
course because obviously the word
tutorial is way more popular than course
when people are searching and I can add
as many comparisons as possible maybe
I'm going to type in learn Python are
people searching for the word learn
Python well not really because python
tutorial is still way more popular so
this is a great way to figure out what
people are searching for so you can
title your videos appropriately
so I want to briefly talk about traffic
sources or where views come from a
traffic source is how a viewer found
your video to watch the traffic source
breakdown for most channels on YouTube
looks more similar to this this is my
robot family Channel and this is the
free coke amp Torah Channel you can see
most of the views on the robot family
channel are coming from suggested videos
and that's where when people so when
someone's watching a video and on the
side there'll be recommended videos on
the side and then when people click
those videos that are recommended on the
side that's a suggested video now you
can see the number two spot is browse
features this includes many things but
the main thing browse features includes
is the home screen so when someone goes
to youtube.com and they're signed into
their account YouTube will recommend
specific things right on the home page
of YouTube and that's browse features so
most channels on YouTube get most of
their views from these things suggested
videos and browse features however you
can see over on the free coke amp side
we get most of our views from YouTube
search and I think this is pretty common
for tutorial channels because if
someone's gonna watch a tutorial usually
they know they want to watch a tutorial
like for instance if someone just
watching like a funny cat video and then
suddenly on the side it says watch this
five hour javascript video people
generally aren't going to want to go
directly from the funny cat video to the
500 JavaScript training video so that's
why YouTube search is I think more
important for 4 tutorial channels but
for a lot of the other channels the
suggested videos are going to be more
important and this is also why I think
titles are more important for tutorial
channels because of the search and the
thumbnails are more important for like
software entertainment channels and
software informational channels
the YouTube algorithm is what decides if
your video is going to be promoted in
different places like if it's gonna be
promoted on cert or if it's going to be
recommended and the YouTube algorithm is
a mysterious thing it's my belief that
even YouTube engineers don't completely
understand how it works basically it's
all based on machine learning and
artificial intelligence the the the
people that program the algorithm they
just tell if the outcomes they want and
then that algorithm determines how to
best achieve those outcomes so ever I'm
about to show you I'm about to tell you
the things I figured out about how to
how to get your video popular but there
could be exceptions to everything I'm
about to tell you this is just based on
a lot of experience and a lot of
research and things i've heard that
other popular youtubers have said okay
let's start with talking about what the
algorithm doesn't care about asterik
that just means that all these things
that algorithm does care about a little
tiny bit but just not that much compared
to what the algorithm does care about
which i'll be talking about next so the
first thing is upload frequency i've
heard people say that creators must
upload a video every few days with no
breaks to really grow a channel this
seems like a myth to me I've seen many
channels with infrequent uploads that
get a ton of views on each video and I
believe that YouTube's algorithm does
not care that much about upload
frequency sometimes YouTube engineers
will actually run studies to better
understand how the algorithm works and
on an official YouTube channel aimed at
creators they discussed a study that
showed that taking a break from creating
videos does not impact the view count
when a creator comes back from a break
so while upload frequency is not always
correlated with how many views you get
it could impact whether a viewer will
subscribe to your channel if you haven't
uploaded for a while a user will be less
likely to subscribe next is video tags
YouTube representatives
officially said that YouTube tags count
as almost nothing when it comes to
recommendations everything has some
amount of impact but this is one of the
lowest impact items so you don't have to
spend too much time on the video tags
although you might as well still put
them in there because it has a very tiny
impact the algorithm looks for patterns
so once it determines that videos from
your channel are often watched by a
certain type of user it will just keep
recommending your videos to that type of
viewer no matter what the tags and the
district and the description say so it's
possible that before the algorithm
identifies a pattern for your channel it
will use tags as an identifier next how
well a previous video performed in my
experience the performance of the
previous video has very little impact on
a subsequent videos performance this is
true both on my channel and then other
channels I've observed however I think
it could impact how quickly a video gets
popular so if a user just watched a
video from your channel the algorithm
may be more likely to recommend a new
video from your channel right after
what's posted but if not many users are
going to click to watch it and they
don't watch fair prefer very long the
algorithm will quickly stop recommending
that new video on the other hand if not
many people watched your previous video
your video may not get recommended a lot
at first but if lots of people are
clicking on it and they are watching it
for a very long time YouTube will start
recommending it a lot I've seen
countless examples of extremely popular
videos coming right after an unpopular
video descriptions these do matter to
the algorithm a little bit just very
little compared to click-through rate
and average view duration which is what
I'm going to talk about later of what
the algorithm algorithm does care about
according to YouTube the first few lines
of a description can be important
especially for searches so you should
fill the first
sentence with as many relevant search
terms as possible when search terms are
lower down in the description they count
less to the algorithm a rookie mistake
is to put links or ads as the first line
in a description while some big-name
YouTube channels do this that's because
the algorithm has already figured out
patterns for where to recommend their
videos for smaller channels you should
always put a keyword rich descriptive
sentence as the first line but remember
even the best description can't make up
for low click-through rates and low
average view duration z' next thing is
subscriber count the algorithm is more
likely to recommend your video to
subscribers so this does have some
impact but I often see very popular
videos on channels with low subscriber
counts and very unpopular videos on
channels with high subscribers if people
don't watch your videos for a long time
it doesn't matter how many subscribers
you have because the algorithm is just
gonna quickly stop recommending your
video to subscribers also subscribers
have to click the bell icon in order to
be notified of every video they don't
click the bell icon then they may not
really be notified of any video on your
channel however there are benefits to
having more subscribers when users
search your videos will appear higher in
the search results if they're subscribed
to your channel also the algorithm is
heavily impacted by patterns if user
clicks on every video from your channel
that appears in the feed then the
algorithm will keep putting more videos
from you in their feed average
percentage of video viewed this one can
have an impact for shorter videos if
your video is just one minute long it
makes a difference what percentage of
the video is viewed but if you're
posting hour-long tutorials the
percentage viewed is much less important
on the freako camp that org channel we
have a four and a half hour long Python
video with over seven million views it's
average view percentage is four point
three percent but it's average view
duration is 11 minutes 20 seconds
average view duration matters way more
than average percentage view
okay this is the important stuff what
the algorithm does care about it cares
about click-through rate and average
view duration basically just those two
things if your videos have a high
click-through rate and high average view
duration nothing else matters your video
will be popular click-through rate
measures how often viewers watch the
video after seeing the thumbnail on
YouTube you need to have a thumbnail
title that people will want to click on
average view duration is how long people
are watching your video on average your
video needs to hold viewers interest for
as long as possible I heard a popular
youtubers say that their video is almost
always going to be popular if you have
at least seven minutes the availa an
average watch time of at least seven
minutes now that's pretty hard to
achieve so it's like a lot of people
aren't going to get to that seven minute
mark but the close we can get the better
hey there my name is RTC or candy or
real tough candy and I am the founder of
the real tough candy YouTube channel
this channel is a software focused
educational channel the little bit of
entertainment thrown in with a very big
emphasis on web development because
everything is going to the web there is
just so much going on in that sphere
that you can talk about it for a very
long time my goal with the channel is to
simply make people better developers
whether they're aspiring developers
they've been in the business for a few
years or they're tried-and-true
battle-hardened senior devs who have
seen it all my goal is to be part of
their journey and make them better devs
I have videos spanning from awesome
github repos to my experiences with
freelancing to getting started with
freelancing and also the author of a few
books and video courses I've been
producing videos as real tough candy for
about two and a half years if you're
thinking about starting a software
channel on YouTube number one I would
say go for it but I think my most
important advice and the thing I'd
emphasize the most is to do videos that
you care about do topics that you care
about otherwise it just becomes another
drudgery filled task
just Oh time to do another video oh this
person is uploading five days a week I
best I guess I better catch up you're
gonna burn out and then I've done that
I've made that mistake of you know
trying to keep up with the algorithm or
trying to keep up with other people in
this niche you just have to do it your
way and I've been going on camera more
and more I really don't like being on
camera
but people like that they want to see
you even if you are imperfect which most
of us are I know it can be very daunting
I'm always going to have a little bit of
an aversion to being on camera but it's
what people like to see and they like to
see that you're human I don't think you
need to have a passion for it but you
should have an interest in it that's
really gonna show in the videos that you
make I would love to see more creators
on this platform doing software web
development stuff whether it's tutorials
insights just personal journeys those
are really powerful to our personal
journeys especially for self-taught so
important and I think important afford
the record I hope to see your channel
soon and I'll see in the next video well
you don't have to be uploading all the
time it is good to have a consistent
schedule this helps people know that
you're probably gonna upload again
pretty soon so it's worth subscribing to
the channel
now if you aren't gonna publish very
frequently I would say it's probably
better to have more substantial content
like if you're gonna create a three to
four hour like Python tutorial it's
probably okay to upload maybe every
month or two but if you're gonna upload
shorter content like shorter
informational content you may want to
upload more frequently like once a week
or twice a week or maybe like two times
a month or something like that so
consistency also kind of helps you to to
kind of motor get get motivated I know
if you have a consistent schedule you
try to stick to it all the time we'll
help you motivated to continue with that
schedule to help with consistency you
should create goals for yourself an
effective goal is measurable timed and
can
trouble measurable means that the goal
should have a quantified component that
lets you know whether you've reached or
not timed just the goal should have a
specific and realistic deadline
controllable means that you should is
should be an action you can perform
rather than an outcome you want for
example your goal may be to put out one
video measurable per week timed note
that put out a video is an action you
can perform but reach 1000 subscribers
is not an action but an outcome you
should create goals that are ambitious
but still doable this will depend quite
a bit on your stage of life if you're a
single person with no job you'll be able
to create much more content than a
married person with three kids and a
full-time job
when thinking about making money you
must know what your goals are
now some people just want to provide
free free learning resources and they're
not really concerned about making money
but most people aren't able to invest
time into creating resources unless
they're compensated a bit here are a few
common ways that your software channel
can make you money we'll go over all of
these one at a time for most people the
primary way a software YouTube channel
will help you make money is through
helping you get a new job or a raise I
already mentioned that starting a
YouTube channel was really helpful for
me when I went to get my first software
developer job and I've heard similar
stories from a lot of different creators
so let's hear first-hand from Jessie
Weigel about how live-streaming
helped him in his career live coding was
so helpful whenever I was looking for a
job and going on interviews which was it
was unexpected to me but seeing that I
did the live coding
on my resume and being able to watch my
my shows I think got me more interviews
than anything else that I did so and
employers already knew what they were
getting when when they called me in for
the interview normally it's like you
know it's kind of a mystery what the
person is really gonna be like you can't
tell that much you know from a resume or
a portfolio but being able to see my
thought process while encoding made me a
more attractive candidate because it
took some of that that question out of
it I was like what are we getting into
so it's a big commitment when you hire
somebody so being able to show you know
my skills and my personality my thought
process you know online through live
coding was just it was a big bonus and
to potential employers also when I went
on the interviews
that I got asked about my live coding
experience more than anything else
everybody wanted to know about it I
guess it's something that it seems like
a lot of other developers are curious
about or they wonder like how how could
you do that just the idea of being able
to make mistakes in front of all those
people or being able to talk you know so
much while you're coding and that's
another aspect that that was very
helpful when I actually did get an
interview and I had to do a coding
exercise one of the big things that
people are looking for is that you know
they don't they don't want to know if
you can just do the coding exercise they
want to know your thought process your
problem solving skills so I already had
so much practice at explaining what I
was doing while I was doing it through
live coding so that was that was perfect
so when I went in there it was just it
was totally normal for me to just say
what I was thinking as I was doing it so
in a very unexpected way live coding
definitely helped helped me get
interviews and help me prepare for
interviews the next way you can make
money is through YouTube ad revenue but
you probably won't make that much money
this way most channels earn between $1
and $2 $0.50 u.s. dollars per 1,000
views but it is possible to earn less or
more than that so if you want to make
thirty thousand dollars in a year you
may have to get thirty million views the
free code camp that org channel is
ad-free however my personal robot family
channel shows ads and I generally get
about $1 to $1 50 cents per 1000 views
for videos under 10 minutes and $2.00 to
$2.50 per 1000 views for videos over 10
minutes at 10 minutes you are allowed to
add
roll ads and I was very surprised with
how much extra money that made me you
only make money on video ads if people
click on them or watch at least 30
seconds of the ad if they click on skip
ad you make no money also the amount of
money you make per ad is dependent on
the country that the viewer is in some
viewers will make you more money than
other viewers this is one of the reasons
there is such a big difference in how
much money you can make one of the more
effective ways to make money on YouTube
is to use easier YouTube channel to help
promote your paid courses
maash from the program with mas YouTube
channel seems to do pretty well with
this model for this to work best you
need to create multiple high quality
complete courses release some full
courses for free on YouTube and use
those courses to advertise your paid
courses some people go about this in the
wrong way they'll create this full paid
course and just release just like a
portion of it on YouTube and hopefully
that portion will encourage people to
buy the paid course that's the wrong way
to do it what you want to do is create
two full length courses release one full
length course on YouTube for free and
use that to help promote your other full
length course if you just released a
small portion of your course on YouTube
it's not going to generate as many views
so not as many people are gonna watch it
they're not gonna want to watch this a
partial course so then you won't get
very much promotion for your paid course
but if you release a full course on
YouTube then you're really gonna get a
lot of people watching that and a lot of
views for your full paid course many
people who create software tutorials
have had success with patreon let's hear
some tips from Kevin Markham who has had
a lot of success with patreon hi there
my name is Kevin Markham and I teach
data science in Python through my
youtube channel which is called data
school I've been using patreon to
support my page for about a year and so
I'd like to share two things
with you number one who should start a
patreon page and number two seven quick
tips for being successful on patreon so
who should start a patreon page well I
would recommend that if you are
interested in building community and
then delivering value to that community
then you are a good fit for using
patreon if your only motivation is to
make money then I don't recommend
patreon quite frankly unless you are
legitimately famous putting a link to
patreon from your YouTube channel page
is not gonna suddenly bring in a lot of
money instead I'm doing well on patreon
requires a lot of work and so unless
you're really interested in doing that
work and enjoy that work it's not a good
use of your time and you're gonna burn
out and that's not good for you or for
your fans okay let's move on to my seven
quick tips for being successful on
patreon tip number one deliver a lot of
value to your audience for free before
starting a patreon page the reason is
this very few people are gonna support
you financially unless you've already
demonstrated to them that you can create
great videos that they love tip number
two try to build a following outside of
YouTube so that you have more ways to
communicate with your audience social
media is one option for this but even
better is starting an email list and
getting them to subscribe tip number
three study successful patreon pages and
check out their rewards and how they
describe the value they're offering that
will help you to refine your rewards and
how you communicate your value
proposition tip number four before you
launch draft your patreon page and share
it with some of your top fans to get
their feedback that'll help you to
determine whether you're offering the
right rewards and at the right price
is tip number five when you launch talk
with your fans authentically about
patreon and why they should join give
them some time to join and you can
remind them every now and again but
don't try to make them feel guilty for
not becoming a patron tip number six
once people join build that community
that we've been talking about create
meaningful ways for you to interact with
your patrons and ideally give them ways
to interact with each other
tip number seven deliver value to your
patrons offer them bonus content and
cool rewards do special things for them
when you can thank them frequently and
above all else prioritize them over the
rest of your fans because they're
supporting you financially and keep
doing this every single month because
patreon is a marathon not a sprint
okay I hope these tips have been helpful
to you good luck with your channel and
with your patreon page many creators
make money through videos sponsorships
killed curry has some great tips for
making money through sponsorships hey
everyone its Caleb thank you both for
having me I'm gonna be sharing with you
guys how you can get sponsors for your
content I'm actually really excited that
you reached out to me for this because
I've tried various ways of monetizing my
content I've tried courses I've tried
monthly subscriptions and for me nothing
has really clicked other creators have
done a great job and that's awesome they
should keep doing that but I found that
my true skill is with these sponsorships
it's how I've made the majority of my
income and it's how I'm able to do
YouTube as a full-time project now how
do you actually get that first sponsor
the number one way I have found that I
was able to get sponsors and I'm still
getting sponsors today is with a contact
form on my website
consider it a landing page a lead page
whatever you want to call it essentially
a way a company can fill out the form
say what they're interested in put their
email and click submit when you have
something like this on your website you
are able to control the the flow of
customers so you're they're not being
distracted by other
things to click on yeah they might go to
other parts of your site but if you put
your stuff up on social media or other
websites you are competing against
thousands of other people but on your
own site you are the the sole owner of
that website and you can control the
experience on that website which means
your going to get much higher quality
leads and the conversion is going to be
much higher if you get someone to check
out that sponsorship page they're very
highly highly likely to fill out that
form at the bottom the second thing is
that you can share this form with your
audience or link to it on the homepage
of your website you don't want it to be
the only thing people see like my
goodness this guy will not stop
advertising his sponsorship
opportunities but you also don't want it
to be hidden where a company would have
to search for it you want companies to
be able to easily reach out to you in a
professional way and three go through
the added effort to refine your niche
and make your value proposition
extremely clear you should have a
general niche
maybe it's programming or maybe it's a
web development or app development
whatever it is you start with that in
stage three of my little plan I have
here you refine that and get very clear
about what a sponsor is going to get
from sponsoring your series step four is
to try to quantify the value that you're
offering them you don't want to scare
them off with numbers like if you're
just trying to get a sponsor you don't
need to give them the ROI and the
conversion rate of clicks and also just
don't overwhelm them with information
unless they specifically ask but for
your sake and also for the sake of
getting new sponsors you should probably
have some way to measure the performance
of your advertisements the performance
of your videos and what you can do is
you can build tracking links in your
description and you can see what the
click-through rate is you know maybe a
video gets 10,000 views a hundred people
click it and two people sign up you've
essentially taken a view count and
figured out how many signups that
translates to now it is vague and
different companies have different goals
some are going to want signups and some
are just going to want brand awareness
so you got to be open and flexible but
you should ultimately have
some perspective on how well your
channel does and how well a sponsor is
going to perform on your channel so for
all of my sponsors they go through a
trackable link that I can see how many
clicks they've gotten Step five is start
to grow your sponsorship base obviously
any time you can get a repeating sponsor
that is great but being open to
different sponsors without just taking
anything is going to be good for your
brand as well because that gives a
larger variety to your content and
allows you to be creative in the types
of advertisements which by the way try
to make your ads creative I do skits
I'm excited in my ad spots you don't
want to be one person in your videos and
a totally different person in your ad
spots they should be the same thing so
step five is to grow that sponsorship
base and just get more experience doing
it and start increasing your prices to
where you can actually make a
substantial amount of money and now
we'll move on to step 6 and for me I'm
somewhere between five and six so this
is exactly where I'm at right now step
six is to try to productize or
standardize your sponsorships so far
I've just kind of been working with
whatever the company's going for you
know I'm trying to meet their needs in
an exact way but now I'm to the point
where I'm getting lots of sponsorship
requests and I can start saying no on
the regular I can also increase prices a
lot because of the demand so as an
example you could say hey you can get
twenty to thirty second ads embedded in
my videos you can get eight of them for
this many dollars
once you productize your stuff it makes
it easier to automate the process and
make your life a whole lot easier
so I'm refining my contact me form to
have those options the company can say
exactly what they want and it takes the
mental stress off of me to have to come
up with a brand new idea every time a
company reaches out to me so those are
just the basics if you want more details
I'm releasing more entrepreneurship
content on my channel as well as app
development and where those two come
together I'd love to have you guys I'm
not gonna advertise but go check out my
channel I'm just playing thank you and
let me know what you guys think what
tips would you have for sponsorships
promoting can be challenging if you're
just starting out you must think about
your target audience could come across
your videos here are some ideas you can
post irrelevant sub reddits or you may
want to submit to a coding newsletter
like the code newbie newsletter or maybe
what you can share on programming forums
such as the freak Ocampa org forum now
note about forums it's more appropriate
to share on forums that you're already
active on for instance if you're already
active on the free code camp that org
forum there'll be a great place to share
your videos but there if there are other
forums that you're already active on
that could be a better place to share
your videos another option is to get
your video published on a more popular
channel for instance the free code cam
channel we publish tutorials from a lot
of different contributors and if your
goal is just to get your video in front
of as many people as possible the free
code camp channel could be a good option
so if you want to submit a video to me
here's my email address buh at freak
Ocampa
org we may be able to publish your video
on our channel also maybe you'll find a
different channel that you can submit
your videos to if you want to kind of
take advantage of an an audience that
already exists okay let's just end with
some miscellaneous tips first of all
consider adding in screens to your
videos they can lead to many more views
especially if you create shorter videos
on my personal robot family channel I
get six percent of views from in screens
if a video is part of the playlist
always link to the playlist in the
description there's nothing worse than
coming across a really great video
that's part of a series but then you
can't figure out how to get to the other
videos in that series so playlist in the
description if you have already created
a full course with lots of individual
videos consider combining them into one
long video if you really want to post
the videos individually never upload
them all at once
make sure to space out each video by at
least a few hours one per day would be
best because if you upload them all at
once they may appear in the wrong order
on your channel and it's better for them
to appear in the correct order it makes
it easier for people to find the right
video in the series
next always expect that each video will
be the first video from your channel
that many people will see if you want to
grow your channel try to maximize the
number of new people who are stumbling
upon it
some creators make the mistake of just
making videos further subscribers this
results in videos that may be confusing
for someone new to the channel you
should always include a quick update
about where people can get prior
knowledge expected especially if viewers
need prior knowledge from other videos
on your channel next never include
background music in a coding tutorial
it's often distracting if people want to
listen to music while watching a
tutorial they can turn on their own
music obviously this doesn't apply for a
software in a team video and other types
of videos but a coding tutorial never
used background music you may want to
use it in an intro or an outro but not
during the the main part of the video
next if you are including a series name
in the title it should be at the end of
the title for instance if you have a
video that's called JavaScript tutorial
- lists like maybe you're creating this
JavaScript series and you're on a video
that's just about lists put the word
lists at the beginning of the title and
the word JavaScript tutorial at the end
of the title okay
now you pretty much know everything you
need to know to get started with your
own software YouTube channel and if you
have any other tips or questions just
leave them in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe thanks for
watching